[Music]
he
e
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
s
w
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
n
what's up everyone welcome to the lobby
gam spots weekly hangout where we talk
about video games here on videogames.com
as it were I'm not Daniel DWI you
probably figure that out by now I'm not
Pete Brown I'm not Justin hawald I think
I'm probably like the what fourth string
Lobby host I guess I don't know you're
stuck with me today sorry uh we'll have
fun anyway I'm here with Jake Decker hey
how's it going it's pretty good it's my
first I'm hosting Lobby should be fun
though Mary's been telling me not to
screw it up too badly so hopefully I can
you know so you're going to screw pretty
bad I probably already have somehow
she's probably I probably broke
something I don't know what have you
been up to today news we're doing news
this week in the office so just shot
news that's that's about it we're going
to be talking about some news later on
with NX rumors and whatnot Pete Brown is
here hi you'll be here the whole show
today I will be and I messed up my
hosting duties on the lobby in the first
sentence so you've already done better
than I have how many senses have I
gotten seven by my count
including that question no including
this one we're not going to do this this
is forever what are you working on
lately aside from the headlander review
which we'll get into shortly yeah uh I
don't know I was just looking up who was
that director I was showing you clips
from Al J jorski Alexandro jorski J
people probably know who is probably and
yeah uh yeah I was watching that stuff
because apparently he almost did a
version of Dune starring Mick Jagger
Salvador DOI Orson Wells the fact that
Salvador Deli is in a movie almost
almost yeah this is this is a real thing
that almost happened and apparently it
was just because it didn't get enough
distribution commitment in the US so it
got pulled super weird yeah you sent me
the trailer for a different movie oh
yeah for um Holy Mountain if you want to
watch a messed up trailer go check that
out it's uh it's really bad Justin hayal
came over to my desk and I had
headphones in so he didn't hear the
weird soundtrack playing and it was it's
creepy it's unsettling I don't know
there you go that's what I been up to
unsettling things yeah what' you say
creepy unsettling things oh yeah it's
like there a weird subg genre of horror
just weird Holy Mountain trailers yeah
we'll talk about it on dead air podcast
which I'm plugging right now already
plugging it all right uh anyway all
right let's get into it headlander
headlander double find's newest entry in
their storied roster I guess I know you
reviewed it Pete let uh I did jump into
it what' you think uh okay well I I
really like this game it is sort of a
con it's like a Metroid game I'm going
to avoid Metroid Vania because it
borrows a lot more from Metroid than it
does Castlevania um and so what that
means is you have this big sprawling map
with a lot of hidden items you want to
find that give you incremental upgrades
to your abilities and that's all well
and good it's like a formula we've seen
before but headlander has this one
conceit where your character is just a
head that's in a jar with a rocket and a
vacuum on the bottom of it and so you
can play as just a head flying around in
space and ramming into enemies and doing
what you have to do or you can pop off
uh the heads of robots take over their
bodies and use the skills that they have
uh sort of inherent to to their
individual robot body and all of this is
presented in a world that is heavily
influenced by 70 sci-fi both like the
high quality production stuff you may
have seen in something like 2001 and
then like the more campy things like uh
zarov I think that's called the uh who
is in that again Sean connory really
weird sci-fi anyway something like so
it's just a weird amalgamation of 70s
sci-fi and Metroid and it it works
really well it's very interesting the
gameplay felt uh just totally novel
because you are lit a head that Is
possessing bodies I saw like the the
blur on your character is kind of like
that 70s movie poster Vibe at certain
points it's like that rainbow that's
referred to as chromatic aberration yeah
that's actually like a a technique
that's used in games a lot nowadays um
and what's interesting is like you are
sort of like this anomaly in the world
and whenever you like walk through a
door or like a robot detects you it says
aberration detected it's a funny inside
joke isn't that just so funny yeah I
don't I didn't actually I saw in a
trailer I think or maybe like gameplay I
was watching I didn't really get the
joke yeah no it's it's a a joke but but
the game is packed with a lot of things
cuz the world is like essentially a
world for heess robots where drugs and
sex are sort of like their favorite
activities and so everyone is either
like you know high like tripping out
like having a hard time grasping reality
or just trying to get laid um so you're
you're kind of naturally yeah so you're
you're navigating this Society trying to
sort of combat uh this robot that is
controlling everything
Methuselah and um you're trying to
locate Methuselah and figure out why you
are just ahead and how you can escape
this weird Society I was watching your
uh video review Which Scott did the V4
but you wrote Of course reading your
review too and you say it's weird at
first that you can't jump but then that
kind of gets eradicated right away
because you're a floating head right
yeah like because you you assume it's a
action platformer that you should be
able to jump um and you can't but the
head can fly around and there's no limit
to the amount of like fuel you have
there's nothing like that you just fly
indefinitely and so it you sort of go
you know if you're a robot you're
running rning around and jumping but
then when you're ahead it kind of feels
like you're playing um like a submarine
based game where you're just like
swimming underwater CU you can literally
just like turn and fly and do all this
fun stuff so you don't really miss the
act of jumping because you can get from
you can get anywhere more efficiently
than you could even if you were jumping
because you can just fly to any point of
any map it's one of those things with
double find games I'm not like super
familiar with any of their games aside
from like Grim Vango but you can kind of
sell each game in like a sentence right
you're like you know Brutal Legend is
like a I don't know like a a Ro's Dre
dream world uh like this you're a
floating head in a 70s sci-fi like Metro
Vania as it were uh and then you know
like Psychonauts you're exploring
someone's head literally as an astronaut
I don't know is this uh you're exploring
as an head as a head too in this I guess
yeah you're this is more of like a
literal translation in aead yeah I mean
the double Find humor is always like
it's the humor and the dialogue that I
always take as the veins that run
through each of their games that still
present here there's a lot of it uh
almost too much uh because there are
some robots and like doors like talk to
you when you walk through them and those
lines get kind of repetitive so you do
hear a lot of the same dialogue over and
over again but certainly for the first
like 75% of the game everything is fresh
and funny uh every robot you can talk
every like NPC in the environment that's
just hanging out you can talk to them
and they all have different lines of
dialogue um like maybe five or six each
uh which is actually pretty impressive
it's not just like one or two right so
you can really just sit around and talk
to robots forever and hear really odd
stuff um you can also possess just
normal robots it doesn't have to be a
combat robot or secure robot like just
any sort of citizen of this world you
can take over and each distinct body has
its own dance so there's a dedicated
dance button that is just nothing but
for pure entertainment some some of the
footage you gave me was just like a
minute of like a horse robot dancing I
think I stuck that in the review I'm
like yeah this has to go in yeah you
know it's just like it's so silly that
like these things are worth mentioning
because they they make it a really just
light experience and like just just fun
to play yeah like overall so you gave it
an eight out of 10 a great out of 10 yes
yeah so you liked it a lot I liked it a
lot I the I had some issues with the
final boss uh in particular because the
game is not that punishing usually if
you die that you respawn in the same
room that you died in like at the door
uh but the game's two boss fights are
multi-stage fights and the first one is
like you know it's maybe a little bit
difficult because you haven't seen a
challenge like it but you can get over
it pretty easily once you recognize the
challenge the final boss same story but
it gives you these things in the the
battle that make it seem like okay I
have to use this to beat the boss trying
to do that I just I died repeatedly like
maybe a dozen or so times So eventually
I resorted to Simply damaging the enemy
retreating letting my health replenish
and just doing that back and forth and
back and forth repeatedly until I
finally whittel their health away that
is like the one thing that I really
didn't like about the game was that
final boss fight because it just seemed
slapped together I guess and you said uh
see in your like negatives review said
there's a couple of like slowdowns do
you mean like technical hiccups uh yeah
there is like some minor slowdown there
is one area in particular where you are
flying through these like really narrow
corridors with lasers bouncing all over
the place on PlayStation 4 it was maybe
10 frames a second like it was really
really slow granted this is like a 30
second slice of the game but it's a
really challenging part um so that was
also a disappointment but not one that
really colored My overall impression as
much as just sort of like you should
know this game isn't perfect technically
so it feels very much like a double find
game though I mean like it fits within
their repertoire or whatever repertoire
yeah yeah it's a French word I think
it's French I just don't
I I don't know I've never been like a
huge double find fan I tried getting
into Grim Vango now that was on like PS4
but I don't know Jake you you played
tough one to get into I feel like it's
it's weird it's very opaque with like
the the puzzles like I like the world
itself the you know D de los MOS kind of
world uh I don't know are you excited
for headlander as like a double fine fan
um not really actually I don't know
after seeing your review I was
definitely more excited I think I'm just
kind of sick of the Metroid like games
um cuz I mean when there's a really good
one there's a really good one and it
seems like this could be this sounds
like a pretty good one I just I don't
know I'm more excited for Psychonauts if
you if you look at something like aium
Verge right which played really close to
the whole Metroid Vania thing this
condenses a lot of the exploration um
like this is like a 10hour game if
you're taking your time okay so
essentially what it what what that means
is that because you're ahead and you can
fly everywhere you have access to every
corner of every room from the very
beginning and it's pretty obvious when
there's like a hidden thing the game
kind of uh like RS that to you with like
there's like a manhole cover on the wall
or something so what you do is you
actually get those little powerups that
make something like a metroid or
Castlevania like feel very rewarding you
get them like at a rapid pace so it's
almost like every minute or two you're
finding a secret room and that that is
kind of like an infectious thing where
you're like cool like I feel like I'm
doing something great and when you find
those it does these like elaborate
flashes of color and light and like all
these weird effects uh so I can totally
sympathize with being over like all
these Metroid vanas this one is an
interesting experiment I think it's at
least worth trying because it really
condenses everything it's super uh
potent what's the thing with Metroid
Vania games were you unsure of whether
to say potent or not no I've I think
I've said that I've like started using
that word lately for some reason she's
going streaks with words third time
you've said it in this this is in this
segment no I think it
is I've been using palpable lately
palpable stuff you find in orange juice
oh wow no just Kidd that's culpable
that's when you touch it culpable is
what you find in your own shoes yeah
Culp uh yeah I don't know so I
mean sorry we're going off the rails
here uh I don't know like it that's the
thing with Metroid Vania games right
Symphony night is one of my favorite
games I really like to axi IM Verge uh
some of the fun is going back and
finding like everything you possibly can
there's a sense of ownership you get
over the world when you know exactly
like you kind of you know like ax ver
you could Mark spots on the map be like
oh this this like phase through the wall
ability is going to let me get down
there do you have any urge to go back
and finish off everything or you kind of
done with a game I'm done with the the
game and I completed it I think at like
68% something like that but I had I had
acquired most of the upgrades of most of
the items um there's like an upgrade
path where you collect like things like
it's like energy or something else you
can spend that and I had unlocked all of
the base things I could have boosted
their abilities but you know I felt like
I kind of saw everything that I needed
to see you get one ability as the head
that lets you charge through these like
rainbow colored barriers so you can go
back and break those down and find some
items but I don't feel totally inspired
to do that tell me can you tell me a
little more I probably should asked this
earlier about the main character like
what is do they explain why your head
detaches or why you're just a head in a
jar they do but it's it's a spoiler if I
explain it at the beginning you don't
they justify that you're just a floating
head yeah yeah right like it's at the
beginning you can pick like you know a
young you know whatever like 20 30y old
male or female or like an older man the
character doesn't really have much of an
identity um but you are sort of being
Guided by this voice on the other end of
your helmets equipment named Earl and
he's just like well looks like you've
woken up we should probably get you out
of here now like you're the last of your
kind we better get going and so he kind
of guides you to Methuselah and at that
point you learn more about the character
but the story here really isn't that
important to the game overall um it's
really
about the strange gameplay and the
strange world that you're exploring
would you say it's kind of a rare case
where the the dialogue and the humor
comes second to the gameplay with double
F or do you find that's often the case I
don't uh i' hate to make a comparison
because I'm not that not to generalize
anything but like I mean I don't know
again I I'm just curious about how like
they interweave I guess it's uh there's
certainly a lot of attention given to
the world uh I'd say maybe a bit more
than the gamepl um you sort
of you you gain access to new security
levels by picking up a robot of a
different color and that's like there's
a clear line of progress there and uh
each robot's weapon has a laser that
bounces an additional time off a wall
that's about as deep as the mechanics
get when it comes to puzzle solving so
surely there there's a lot more to
unravel when you're exploring the world
and talking to characters and just
observing sure and this is out now this
is out now PC PS4 yeah cool well that is
headlander you could see Peter Brown's
review on gamespot.com should be right
at the top of the page as of now if
you're watching this uh in the future
still just search for It Go the
headliner page PC PS4 how much is it uh
$20 and I think 15 right now for
PlayStation plus people cool so there
you have it go check that out and uh
read Pizza review see whether you like
it or not and that's that moving on we
are going to talk about we happy few
which is in uh Early Access now on Xbox
One and PC uh don't know a ton about
this game really despite the fact that
we've seen kind of a lot of gameplay now
which is weird turns out a lot of us
didn't know a lot about this so Jay we
brought you in because you were on the
stream with uh Jean Luke this morning
right yeah so I've actually been playing
a lot of it this weekend and it is
definitely not what I think people were
expecting I'm sure if you were like
following this close enough um You
probably would have known that there
were Rog likee aspects to this to this
game but as someone or as PE as people
just kind of saw it at E3 um people are
probably going to be surprised because
it's not at least not yet it's not story
heavy okay so can you tell me like what
the demo encompasses I doesn't it it
starts with like what we saw the E3 it
starts with that weird like Bioshock
esque like Brave New World I guess like
to be a literary snob the kind of all
this Huxley like they take the the drug
called Joy or like equilibrium Which is
less that's like more of like a dude bro
action movie with Chris Bell stops
taking the drug he's a grammaton cleric
I know you know I know I know equilibri
so you know the movie yeah no it's it's
uh it's just the same conceit right
they're it's like a dystopia where like
uh emotions are banned or no in this
case same thing as like so everyone
needs to be happy um and you have to
take a pill every so often they they
didn't go into specific how often you
need to take it but every time you take
it then things look brighter and happier
and you see rainbows and things like
that but in the intro which is kind of
interesting you can decide to take the
pill or not to take the pill if you take
the pill the game ends if you don't take
the pill then it goes through that intro
that they showed at E3 which is really
cool um it really sets the sets the mood
for the game um it seems very
story-driven at that point but once you
get out of that uh you're kind of just
dropped in a randomly generated world
and you're kind of left to survive um
there are missions to follow um there
are quests to do but there isn't much of
a story yet there's supposed to be three
though three different characters and
three different stories eventually oh
interesting cuz yeah like what it
immediately strikes me as a survival
kind of like Rog light game what's going
on here watching crazy leg get his butt
kick well that's what I did I played I
think it was like pax's Prime last year
when I first played this like an Xbox
showcase and I remember playing and just
like these six people chased me into a
house and I was beating them away with
clubs for about 10 minutes cuz that's
all I had and then I started punching
them and I I think I died so that
happens yeah did that die did that
happen a lot on the stream no I died
once on the stream but it
was H can you go more into detail about
the survival elements like uh how is
there like thirst or anything is it like
deep or is it kind of just a it's not
super deep it's you have to drink water
you have to eat food and you have to
sleep those are the three things and
then you can get sick you can get the
plague um actually in like you can also
get sick too so not just in the plague
if you eat like rotten food you're going
to get sick um actually one of the ways
I died actually was that I got sick I
started puking and I puked up anything I
ate anything I drank until I starve and
uh I starve to death and I like thirst
to death what is that you die of thirst
thirst there we go you drank too much
water is that what thirst to death is
yeah that that's that's like a water
poisoning H2O pretty much too what's the
joke uh guy walks into a bar says I'll
have an H2O second guy walks in I have
an h202 second guy dies what is it
hydrogen peroxide it's a chemist joke I
hang out a lot of chemists you do yeah
but yeah no so we have Pete we were
talking before this about how like I
again none of us know like how like the
overall veins of the game like what it
completely how it's going to play
through like as you're like going from
beginning to end or dying and restarting
and whatnot but you know there's kind of
been this Resurgence of Rogue lights I
guess in the last like five years or so
cuz like smaller teams can make them I
guess like uh you know hello games is
doing no man SK is 12 people or they
made Nomad Sky it's 12 people and
they're kind of you know there's there
algorithms that allow them to make
bigger games without like certain assets
and whatnot I don't know does this kind
of game does this game specifically
interest you but also like are you kind
of interested in Rog lights in general
no I'm
not all right I was you know when they
first showed this game I was totally
interested in the narrative uh you know
concept and I played a demo that was
definitely packed with like more
characters and sort of like action
oriented moments but then watching your
stream and watching this game play right
now I I'm you know it doesn't seem to
communicate a very strong identity of
like what the world is just in the the
the wandering and Gathering and fist
fighting Crazy Legs like I don't I don't
really get a lot out of that so I'm not
seeing a game that really interests me
at the moment okay are you not into
survival games either that not typically
I don't gravitate towards them um I mean
if you want to consider Fallout a
survival game like sure I like Fallout
but I don't play like you know uh what
was that one starve Don't Starve I don't
play Don't Starve yeah I didn't play
stressful game I don't play stuff like
that I guess so it is considerably less
stressful than Don't Starve okay um and
like you I'm actually not that
interested in these kind of games either
um but I did kind of stick with it it
took a while um but it it's actually
like I think it does have an identity I
think it they're still kind of trying to
figure some of the details out maybe
yeah um but I think I think a lot of
people like will enjoy this even if you
don't like Rog likes because it's not
you're not going to be dying constantly
it's not like trying to be challenging
and in a sense it's more it's more about
that exploration and like your goal is
to escape basically um at least from
this so like each area you get to
there's new things that kind of help you
put put you towards that goal to get to
joytown I think is what it's called
Wellington anyway but it's where
everyone's really happy and if you don't
look happy that the cops will beat the
crap out of you it's not so much that I
don't like the the inherent stress of
survival it's how you can attach
yourself to that world and whether it's
fun to play or not so I'm looking at
this and I'm not seeing something that
looks particularly fun if survival is
the only
thing I I don't know that just doesn't
do it for me yeah I mean I hope I mean I
hope that eventually maybe they'll add
something where you can kind of turn
those things off um and just have a more
story focused game especially when they
add it add that story mode or main quest
yeah if there's a story mode I'm in like
I'll do that I guess yeah I mean just
because like
it's fun but it gets annoying after a
while and like there are water fountains
like so often it's like why is this even
a problem like if I just step outside
drink water and then I'm fine like right
it almost seems like just hard food yeah
well the food's a little tougher to come
by but there are humans walking
everywhere that's true you can hum how
how fast do you think you'd resort to
cannibalism if something like this went
down immediately yeah I've been waiting
do you want to eat me right now yeah
it's like the road that creepy scene
where they go to the basement and uh V
Vig morganstein finds all the people in
the basement they have to sprint out you
know he was in that movie I was talking
about earlier the witness really the
honish people moving on yeah we you sent
me a lot of weird movie recommendations
today I didn't recommend either of those
movies you recommended Blair Witch 2 I
still haven't watch that oh don't watch
that uh incidentally there's Blair Witch
3 anyway we're kind of getting off track
with vgo um turning into dead air yeah
that's just I'm just trying to morph
this into my horror podcast uh that's
the thing there's you know you're saying
there's three branching storylines uh
it's just Early Access right now so who
knows what's going to happen the
developers said their plan is to keep it
in Early Access for 6 to 12 months it
doesn't have a full release date from
what I understand it's on you know steam
Xbox one right now yeah I I'm not sure
what the release date is I'm not sure
what the release schedule is um they
could have talked about it I haven't
looked into it I to be honest I wish
they didn't do early access for this I
wish they just waited and kind of like
finish more because this game is also
really buggy too like last night I was
playing a save I was probably like three
hours in and I got stuck in geometry and
that was it like I just starved to death
there so so you would have lost Don't
Starve there dud that dude just hunched
over in the middle of that scene it's
super weird moving like sick the thing
that Drew me into the game at first was
the art style the aesthetic they're
going for with this kind of you know
this like it looks like the English
Countryside right this dystopia
Wellington joytown which one is it I
don't is it the same place I think
they're the same place okay uh it just
it it strikes me as something I wanted
to play Just based on like the
character's m masks kind of had that
weird like Rapture from Bioshock feel
that trailer during the Microsoft press
conference at E3 hooked me because it
was you know it was like this you just
don't take the drug and all a sudden it
flashes and instead of a pinata was it
you're stabbing a rat or something yeah
so that that's really cool that was cool
that's the intro to this that is the
intro so that's what people will see I I
still don't think people should rule it
out though if they don't like Rog leges
cuz I think I I think this story could
be really cool um but we don't know yeah
it remains to be seen whether you know
it's an early access I doubt they would
just throw all the narrative stuff at
you for the next 6 to 12 months or
whatever they plan to be on Early Access
with but I don't know it's it seems like
maybe they don't they haven't shown how
they're going to marry the narrative
experience with the actual like
overarching survival Rogue Light
Elements yeah and I think that's what's
going to put a lot of people off and I
think that's why I kind of wish this
wasn't Early Access because a lot of
people were expecting like a more
narrative game and I think now people
look it in like oh this isn't this isn't
narrative I don't know if I'm interested
in this anymore do you don't you don't
plan on playing it much more in Early
Access
um I'll play it again I think when
there's more story to it um because what
I have played I've enjoyed I like most
of my problems with it like once I get
used to that world they're just like
little things like I like glitches like
getting stuck in Geometry that sucks um
but then like the the map you have to
pull up your map like every couple
seconds and they have a compass you
probably see it in yeah how's this
inventory how's like the user interface
cuz a lot of times the survival games
that's kind of a tough thing to navigate
the inventory kind of sucks yeah um it's
not streamlined yeah it's it's not super
streamlined but yeah I mean the the the
the compass like it doesn't show where
things are so you're constantly checking
your map which is kind of a pain in the
butt um but I don't know I recommend
people giving it a try I heard somewhere
too that if you get it on Xbox one you
can try the first hour free okay um so
if you're on the fence maybe give it a
shot yeah there's a stigma attached to
Early Access I feel like cuz so many
times people like are worried that
they're not going to deliver on the
promise right like some games get an
early access and stay St there for what
like 2 years isn't it kind of like uh I
forget the percentage of games that go
into Early Access and never make it out
it's staggering and uh I'm hoping like
this game intrigued me especially after
the Microsoft press conference with that
kind of like you know Brave New World
stuff was really interesting to me and I
I do want it for the narrative but I I
as opposed to you guys I really like
survival like Rog light games I love
Don't Starve it's stressful as hell um
You probably like this then I think I'll
try it out like I mean to I just I need
to figure out when I'm going to find
time a cuz I those are games you kind of
want to really dig into but I don't know
we'll check it out definitely for sure
but thanks for uh sharing your
experience with the stream and uh yeah
doesn't sound like you're jumping back
in but I'll try it out I'll check out we
have a few the title itself is really
good it's like part of a sentence like
the last of us it's just ominous it's
part of a sentence yeah no it's not like
it's like a we happy few like what are
they talking about no are they talking
about yeah The Last of Us is this weird
sentence fragment all right anyway
that's that so we have a few
Early Access on Xbox One PC no idea when
it's going to be uh fully out sometime
the next year maybe next year uh because
it's early access maybe never but uh
yeah so go try it out you can download
it there and uh come back to Gamespot
for uh you know more coverage on that
Jake Decker we're gonna sub you out
Justin hawald is right here gonna bring
him on for
uh that was palpable high five is that
coffee you're drinking or like jet fuel
because you seem hyper
it's just cocaine just liquefied yeah
you know you just mix it with a lot of
water cuz you also you get hydrated yeah
failed to mention this but you and I
especially you just recently returned
from San Diego Comic-Con why especially
me just returned because I got home a
day before you did two days before you
did you weren't out you were out at the
office yesterday yes Comic-Con how was
it ComicCon was a lot of fun that was
you know it's a show that's it's so
weird for us there's not a lot of video
game stuff but there's just so much
weirdness around um so so square like we
get to see a lot of these outdoor
activations and like for me those are a
lot of fun even though the heat in San
Diego is just like so sweltering but the
things that you get to do outside like
uh the South Park event normally Ubisoft
takes over this huge area where you can
jump you do parkour and you jump off of
a like 30 30 foot I was going to say 30
story yeah I think would actually kill
you you jump off a 30 foot thing into a
like a big balloon and this year it was
just C cutouts of South Park and Mike
and I did video where we uh you know had
fun with those cutouts I don't want to
know what that means oh yeah no so it
was the it was the anal probe so it's 20
moments from the last 20 years South
Park and the first one was the anal
probe so like I got down where Cartman
was to pretend the satellite was coming
out of me but Justin of course there was
a cow with the utters and Justin you can
probably imagine uh no please you want
me to detail it no there's a few other
ones there was like a PC principal
there's a the video is on our site and
on YouTube but yeah you can see like
that we did the photo shoot for
everything and it was fun we did the Tea
Party did the uh like Jennifer
Lopez pretty much every the most
offensive scenes ever there's not a lot
of new video game stuff there but it but
it is fun to see like oh you we love all
these shows and movies and and things
that are going on around that as well
like another really cool one for me was
the uh a Rick and Morty VR experience
like of course there's a game related to
that they didn't let us record direct
feed for it but just like being around
the the whole Rick and Morty props and
sets and then getting to play this this
game where you get to be a part of the
Rick and Morty show basically and you're
interacting with the characters like I
I'm really excited for that to come out
a little bit wider and it's apparently
going to be a full game here's the
here's the video right now this is what
we
did yeah Justus licking his tears there
we go of course Justin being himself
who's this guy with pan off him uh yeah
this was uh this was one of those activ
there's PC principal all right a lot
like
you wait
okay yeah try not to watch this video at
work if you can help it
oh there's the go God Go episode which I
don't even think I've ever seen Rob was
describing to me they like like otter
had taken over the world when Cartman
woke up or something because he Froze
all right oh they did a panel so um Matt
Stone and Trey Parker also did a panel
uh in one of the really rare instances
where you could just walk into Hall h
and I they're just such funny guys like
I love hearing their insights about the
show and and how most of it is just kind
of an accident and they're kind of lazy
and they're surprised that all of this
keeps going and they just want to quit
you saw that documentary about how they
make an
I need to see I hat it I hated it they
didn't know what they were doing till
the last minute they were like all right
we'll just throw this together and it
works like well that's they themselves
admitted it during was it some panel or
maybe it was at the um Oscars cuz they
were like high on acid yeah they were
peeking when they got out the limo
wearing dresses so they mentioned that
during the during their panel and they
said that someone asked them like hey
what were you thinking were you were
like when you go up for the award and
they're like well you know honestly I
didn't realize anything until we were
sitting down and it was like oh dude I'm
wearing a a dress and you're wearing a
dress where are we and like everybody
else that was taking the award seriously
was pissed at them because they were
just making a mockery of it which is
like why why would you be surprised but
yeah they admitted that like they're
like oh you guys are so current with
your episodes like no we're just lazy
and we wait till the last second and it
just kind of became our schedule which
is kind of like us yeah I guess and
everything that we do a Gamespot man
yeah so anyway secrets so anyway yeah a
lot of San Diego ComicCon cosplay videos
galleries on uh on our website not much
game coverage and you get there if you
go through all of the cosplay galleries
you'll see a special mic wearing a
particular outfit you just have to look
through all of them yeah look through
click through every single one everyone
watching the stream he's wearing a diva
outfit yeah that was me there's a great
junkrat there some good OverWatch uh car
got cosplayed there's junkrat there was
an awesome Reinhardt which the Reinhardt
was amazing he had like sound effects in
his boots when he walked it was it's the
guy that did the Hulkbuster outfit last
year which was also you know insanely
detailed and he made a Reinhardt it's
like full like robotic arms reaching out
jeez yeah it was great yeah go check
that stuff out uh not a lot of game
coverage but anyway we made the best of
it but yeah so we are here today because
we are about halfway through the summer
would you say that say it ain't so yeah
ju July 26th Tuesday July 26th it's like
the day after the 25th yeah continues
going forward these days yeah July's a
weird one where the days go in order um
so I don't know we're we're coming up on
August there are a few big profile games
I guess in that month but we kind of
wanted to talk about what to play the
rest of the summer there's always a lull
I think a couple weeks ago Danny we had
talked about uh games if you miss this
year that you should play that we're
probably going to be talking about for
Game of the Year consideration like I
had said like XCOM 2 the witness play
those if you haven't yet we want to talk
about what's coming out the rest of the
summer there are a few I want to go
chronologically but first I just want to
get out of the way because it's all
anyone's talking about it's no man's Sky
yeah seems like if it works out it's an
ideal summer game right because it can
kill time you can just you know
theoretically you can just be exploring
for you know weeks and weeks and weeks
until September when you're done
exploring the real world in Pokémon go
you go back into your living room turn
off the lights and just avoid the
sunlight and no man's Sky yeah exactly
that's but like we talked about enough
about no man's sky on the lobby we've
covered it we uh you know it's gone gold
it's ready we don't have code for the
review yet who knows when we'll get it
um so we'll just get that out of the way
yeah that's the big profile one but uh I
mean there are a few more in August and
then kind of going into September which
is still a little bit of a September's
pretty light before the fall release
schedule starts October is just an utter
[__] show in a good way September
October is not summer no I know I'm
saying like before we get into the fall
schedule um I don't know so first August
2nd there's a couple games there's abzu
yeah what do you guys think of that you
are you excited for that at all I'm
looking forward to it tell me your abs
like [__] know an AB Zoo it's no it's
just a it's an enclosure of wild ABS
running around oh God but I I played it
recently at a like a e3 and it's you
know like this underwater X um E3 is an
underwater underwater Exposition
eological
enty exam which if you passed you could
be an
enologist um no I played it it's like so
it's very much like not a narrative
maybe but it's this very surrealistic
kind of underwater just exploring for
the sake of exploring sounds like
Journey Mike mhm I think that's the vein
they're going for flower I think the
lead designer or lead artist or
something yeah there's yeah bunch of EXT
joury people on there it's that kind of
watercolor scheme I guess almost the
scheme they're trying to scheme you into
it no but uh the last time I played it
they kind of revealed this like
Supernatural stuff you go into this Lake
within a lake under or lake within the
ocean underneath it and you go into this
weird alternate Dimension I don't know
it it controls pretty well like swimming
is you know historically pretty bad in
video games I think they finally figured
it out like 5 years ago but up until
2011 man swimming was the worst up until
Rayman Origins swimming was awful Rayman
Origins just nailed it you just tap a
button remember another game that did
that Mario I was going to say yeah
nothing new they figured it out like day
one and then just continued to screw it
up with like Majora's Mask which is one
of my favorite games but swimming is bad
in that oh yeah that the water temple
yeah anyway August 2nd that's absu uh
we're also going to have Batman The
Telltale series episode one Realm Of
Shadows I don't know I'm not much of a
Telltale Games fan I recognize their
like recognize like the pedigree that
they're that they have because they're
really good narratives I love Walking
Dead Season one I started The Wolf Among
Us I'm interested to see what they're
going to do with Batman because there a
lot of interesting stories to tell I
just said yesterday they're going to
have multiplayer for the first time yeah
I'm not sure how that works exactly I
don't either I didn't even like click
into it I don't I believe
this I don't know this isn't true this
is not true telltale's got good writers
and their their stories are always kind
of you know like they are well written I
think the characters are welldeveloped
so I'm interested to see their take on
Bruce Wayne um I just get bored with
those games yeah I don't know I I can't
if I'm playing a game I would rather
watch a movie like with those you know
like not that games can't tell a great
story at all but like this kind of game
I just get bored with the mechanics and
it doesn't care you're not reviewing it
yeah oh yeah I'm not reviewing that I
don't think but there are so many good
the that novel style of game something
like uh uh the Phoenix Wright game
coming out like I I'm still excited for
that that narrative experience because
we don't really get that a lot
especially with Western games where
you're basically just enjoying the story
and it's not as much focused on the
gameplay it's just here's a cool
story read it yeah or kind of listen to
it I guess you know those choices they
say it's like that gives you the uh
illusion of choice right but then there
aren't that many the ending is going to
be the same in Telltale Games right
that's the thing with there are very few
branches out then comes back yeah there
are very few endings or maybe there's
two endings what do you think you guys
are going to take the time over the
summer to play this I got too many games
to play I'm not a big Batman guy I think
that's my my hang up here the Batman's
the side I'm excited about like I mean a
lot of people and everybody most people
aside from like cynical Peter Browns
like Batman nowadays so you're a DC fan
uh but now
most of us are Marvel there's going to
be a ttail Marvel game as well I'm a
little bit more excited for that yeah
Marvel yeah see what see if they can
capitalize on this you know like
give that's what I want Telltale anime
yeah just all anime of what property
anything make up your own me Goku give
me Naruto give me one punch man tetso
give me one punch man is that the name
of it one punch man that is the name of
the anime what's that about it's about a
guy I haven't seen much of it it's about
a guy who's pretty expressionless who
doesn't really care about much but he
can defeat anyone with one punch nice
sounds like uh I would listen to an
entire podcast talking with you talking
about anime man it's maybe like we
should make one that just sounds like
Brad Pit from uh
snatch uh remember when you can
understand him they used to like the
subtitles that do question marks at one
point because you don't know what he
said this become a movie podcast all of
a sudden yeah sorry anyway so that those
are both those are both August 2nd
Batman and abzu no man Sky August 9th we
already talked about that we have talked
about it extensively uh and then
probably the other big one for the month
is DSX mankind divided which I am
personally excited for curious about CU
I loved Human Revolution uh mankind
divided looks like it's going to be the
same vein that kind of like uh you know
System Shock Dishonored kind of vein of
you can play through areas like like
it's a shooter but it can be a stealth
game it can be this like narrative game
where you're finding little like tidbits
in the environment to kind of flesh out
the world uh Scott Butterworth has been
covering it he seems pretty positive
about it so far um that's later this
month I don't know they've taken a lot
of criticism as well to heart that it's
not going to be locking you into or it's
not going to especially with the bosses
I think was one of the big problems with
the punish you for going stealy yeah
that if you wanted to do anything other
than combat it's not going to be that
much fun when you get to a boss and
hopefully they do actually solve that
this time I wonder if Adam Jensen is the
same voice actor yeah tell me how you
feel about that Pete I'm just not a fan
no of Adam Jensen it's funny we
transition from Batman just the voice
actor it doesn't sound convincing his
intonation everything I can't you could
put like the cowl on him and you just
think he's Bruce Wayne kinda but like a
poor man's Bruce Wayne that just raspy
over the top like you been drinking
heroin or something who would be a
better Adam Jensen I don't know but the
gameplay clips that I saw from Scott's
uh preview event thing the NPCs had more
convincing voices than the lead
character which just totally threw me
off I I'm very curious about the game at
large I just have to turn down the
voiceover volume or something I don't
know I just read it all in K Reeves
voice yeah oh perfect that's a good
impro but like every video game that has
subtitles in my head I I turn off the
voices and I just hear ke Reeves in my
head that's perfect because he's almost
as monotone as I don't know I'm pretty
monotone yeah take take take this is a
good story take the red pill let's keep
going give the government back their
jobs I don't know what movie that was um
so yeah that's DX mankind of I'm excited
for it it looks like yeah if same thing
with dishonor too if they cannot punish
you for going like the stealth route
which I liked which I'm I love stealth
games I want to do that I play through
both these games like twice Human
Revolution and dishonor one I'm hoping
they can kind of Remedy those problems
that I as well as a lot of people had
Justin you're kind of worried about this
one on August 30th World of Warcraft
Legion oh I'm I'm worried not because of
the game I'm worried because of what it
will do to my productivity in the rest
of my life MH CU like every every time a
new expansion comes out as much as I say
like I'm done I'm done with Warcraft we
don't need to play this anymore but then
the expansion comes you're like well you
know I could play for another you know
100 hours or so just like drop it in you
know just another 100 No Deal they have
closets the trans mography 2.0 like you
can change your outfits on the Fly and
like real life is that so you're telling
me closets is one of the main lures of
this what's going sliding door we
talking like a hinge what kind of
closets here closets give you full
access to your wardrobe even any Quest
you've beat in the past you can suddenly
go back you did any of the choices that
you might have made for equipment in the
past you get both
choices this is huge as someone who has
a passing interest in World of Warcraft
and it was never never really never
really addicted to it at all I never
spent more than probably I don't know 30
hours in it I know s you played 30 yeah
well like 30 there I orc Hunter which I
understand is kind of a noob character
Hunters are easy to level up don't scoff
at me depending on how long ago you did
it if you spent 30 hours like you know 3
or four years ago you're not going to
have made a you probably didn't get a
very big experience if you spent 30
hours in the last year you probably
level cap probably yeah there was a I
not not really there was a joke saying
that they've increased the leveling
really really I'm trusting you with this
cuz I'm just agreeing whole funny you
play World of Warcraft no it's not it's
not funny if you do play World Of test
to that uh but what is it like there's a
lot of is there a story draw I'm
assuming like there's always a lot of
these side quests that kind of there's
another hero that you get to play as
like the last hero that we got got was
death knight and now you're going to get
to play as a Demon Hunter which I I I'm
interested in more I haven't tried it on
the public test Realms but it seems like
an interesting new gimmick to throw in
there um and and of course a little bit
more story increased level cap all of
that gives you more reason to to grind
away in the game MH but I it's something
that always draws you in and we've seen
on subscriber numbers that it it pulls
you in for a limited amount of time and
then the subscribers drop off again and
you're kind of left with that
audience of people who have not stopped
playing Warcraft since it came out which
is still you know more people than I
think any other paid MMO but
is a down a lot from its prime of over
10 million over what 12 14 million back
in the day yeah I've like I said I've
never been like huge into it but I don't
know every time this is the time to join
oh my God are you H or Alliance Alliance
really the alliance all my friends from
high school used to like laugh at
Alliance that's cuz they're wimps they
don't understand Allure of a real team I
mean much like team Valor in Pokémon go
if you're not team Valor I you could
have chosen a dumb team like Mystic or
Instinct but team Valor the alliance
these are just natural choices I haven't
played much Pokémon go but I feel like
if I do I'm going to join Instinct just
to troll everyone as I like to tell
people I'm a Hufflepuff and I like to
say that if I uh if I play Pokemon Sun
Moon I'm gon to pick poo is he the one
that no one likes yeah you know trolling
people by choosing Instinct I think the
the house chooses you as the Harry
Potter fans might say throw on the hat
and see what happens all right last one
in August same day as Legion August 30th
uh this is a game I'm assuming all three
of us played and uh many other people
it's pretty seminal game in the third
person action shooter survival horror
scene resid Evil 4 is coming to
PS4 um and Xbox One are they all coming
to Xbox One PS4 PC yeah remastered uh
what do you guys you you want jump back
into this game I don't have time what do
you want with your time Peter do you
want to I have to play new games not
remasters this it's not even a remaster
it's a port it's just a port I misspoke
with the remaster this is not going to
look any better like 12 versions of this
game which I I like this game a lot but
I'm cool you can get a that was not
Resident Evil 4 by the way no you can
get a physical case you can get a
physical case with this now on PS4 which
as someone who likes Resident Evil a lot
and we talk about in dead air podcast um
uh I'm excited to play I have six5 and
four or six and five now on PS4 I don't
know I'm I'll probably Play It Again
someone told me that at the beginning in
the gados village you know how like you
have to keep fighting at the beginning
until the bell rings and they all go
back to the church I consider myself a
huge fan of the series but someone told
me that if you shoot the Bell yourself
you can just end it right there do you
guys happen to know if that's true or
not maybe the twitch chat can tell me if
it's on like YouTube or something I
don't know because that blows my mind
I've never in like the 10 times I played
that puing that's that's like that boss
fight in midar Solid 3 the against the
end where you can shoot him in his
wheelchair like at the very last second
of the cut scene leading up to the boss
fight and totally negate the whole fight
yeah or you can turn off your your
console for a while come back you would
think the people immediately around you
that's so cool he's the that's the best
boss fight in any game but if they're
waiting for the belder ring and then
they see you shoot the Bell wouldn't
they just go dude dude I saw you I'm not
I'm not going to leave just cuz you sh
I'm waiting for the Bell to ring I'm
going I'm still going to attack you are
they just that dumb I don't know I guess
so well they're they're not like in
their right minds are they are any of us
no I guess not if I would I would not be
surprised if you came like lurching at
me with a butcher knife one time I would
be I would say okay that makes sense our
office is a scary place uh one last game
I wanted to throw in there because not
to like diminish it whatsoever but just
because it's in September it's right
like during kind of the September lull
um which is not something you always say
I guess cuz October is pretty crazy I
don't talk about September that often no
I've never mentioned September in a
sentence no no birthday month take a
guess quick 16th no first day of fall
22nd too slow uh recor is coming out
September 15th I believe yeah uh you
know like uh eaun is attached to it um
Tamor Hussein wrote a good story about
it saying this might be like the real
Mega Man successor you're looking for uh
after a game that didn't do so well
lately that Pete reviewed number n not a
lot of people liked it so recor like a
3D Metroid Prime Mega Man is that
accurate to
say no no Metroid Prime is a first first
person game I get that but although I
will say some of the envir the
environments look pretty similar I
actually don't know a whole lot about
recor um I was surprised to see that the
game was sort of more of a budget title
in a way like it's selling for 40 bucks
and it seems to have an aesthetic that
is maybe befitting last gen rather than
this gen um so I'm but in some ways I'm
that makes me wonder if they're able to
put more time into like weird mechanics
and weird encounters if they're not
wasting a lot of budget on visuals would
say so okay I'm curious about it I'm
curious about it same here we'll see how
that goes that'll be September before
October hits as the year Works September
usually happens September precedes
October comes after August what's the
poem I got halfway through 30 days half
October but September is sometimes
before October if you're counting a leap
year there you have it Justin hawald
everyone all right so that is uh kind of
our wrap up of the games left this
summer things you can get into if you
haven't already caught up on the orous
spring catalog that kind of bombarded us
a lot of good games there uh I don't
know let us know what you think in the
comments what you're looking forward to
playing any recommendations you have for
us uh aside from Pete because he'll
probably be too busy playing other games
and I'm just not into those games
whatever you're going to recommend it's
just not for me no P Pete's gonna Pat
Pete's gonna be a Pete's a reviews
editor he knows what's hot you don't
have to tell him what's hot look I don't
have time for this right now yeah you
just get up and walk away anyway yeah
let us know what you're going to be
playing the rest of the summer but we're
now going to talk about NX rumors which
abound today and I brought you know Pete
you're pretty well versed in the tech
scene as you're yeah tapped into it yeah
you're tapped into it Justin you're
things you have a 3DS so you know
exactly what we're talking about I know
Nintendo so
apparently uh according to Euro gamer I
believe had the original yeah yeah Euro
gamer it was a report from Euro gamer
tomorrow say UK editor at Gamespot wrote
this up um Nintendo's next gaming
platform code name NX will be a portable
console that has detachable
controllers that pretty much confirms
what we already suspected right that
it's going to have nunchucks well mine
is the detachable controllers that's the
weird part right well so the the whole
concept of a detachable device like a
dockable mobile gaming thing was like
kind of refuted by some sources at one
point and so for the past few months
I've been saying like no no no that's
not going to be a thing you've kept
waving that flag and I'm here to lower
my flag because it sounds like if this
is true and it probably could be based
on what they're describing it sounds
like something Nintendo would do um in
some ways it sounds like what we all
thought the Wii U was when it was first
announced because we had that same
confusion when they brought out the Wii
U controller and we thought this is a
self-contained device in itself what an
amazing idea and now five years however
many years later like oh still an
amazing idea please still actually do
that that's it's cool it's like the Wii
U if the Wii U's tablet was much more
like mobile not just portable around
your house or anything I I don't
understand how the detachable
controllers plural work exactly Pete was
you were saying like what maybe like we
modish things on the sides I mean that's
what yeah the sort of illustration they
just popped up there is just sort of
like a little concept right but it is
you know a analog stick at the top of a
remote looking thing and on the bottom
are either buttons or a d-pad depending
on which half you're talking about so
would you would you like cradle it like
play it like this can we get a closeup
of
that what is are you playing bobit no
I'm playing
Zelda do you like the bone
arrow
just the T-Rex trying to play this new
console uh
so it looks like that will be a
controllable option and some people are
talking about okay this will enable
multiplayer on the go right because
everyone will get their own controller
to people not everyone um but you know
what I'm suspecting is that there will
also be a Pro Controller equivalent uh
where you're not going to be expected to
play all your games at home once you
dock the handheld using these two
awkward things right because when it's a
handheld it's all an attached unit and
that has inherent comfort and usability
uh so I think yes those controllers will
be like weote like things that you can
detach and use in various ways but I
doubt that'll be the only controller I'm
I'm going to call this now I think the
attached controllers are actually going
to be
Maracas it's just just a rhythm console
specifically you got some you should fix
your Maracas uh I was hoping for Harps
Accords no okay anyway but so well the
other really interesting thing to me is
the confirmation that it well not I
guess not confirmation the rumor that it
will use
yeah sure and I don't think as weird as
it would be to take that step back I
also don't think it's that farfetched
what that says to me is not necessarily
that all games will be on a cartridge
but that Nintendo will be pushing really
hard for a download-based system that we
will go back to the future that Xbox
that Microsoft talked about years ago at
the launch of the Xbox one which was
shot down I think Nintendo might go
forward with that like if you want to
get every game you're going to have to
download it digitally I think that'll be
like an option but cartridges have an
inherent value for people who don't have
access to fast internet you know things
like that like they if they want this to
be mainstream and sell to a lot they
have to make sure that they're covering
every segment of the market the
cartridges are expensive and ah but
Justin but uh optical disc right right
right right right no no those are cheap
telling Pete I'm tell optical disc you
watched me tell them Optical discs a lot
of moving Parts you got lasers got to
move back and forth you got to spin the
disc all this stuff creates a lot of
noise and takes a lot of intricate um
you know
Machinery uh a flash drive you know like
a cartridge yes it's a little bit more
expensive to prod produce but you but
you have a thing that is not generating
a lot of heat it's not making a lot of
noise it's very simple you just sort of
read the the pins on it and there you go
so I think this is more of a move to
give provide storage in a way that makes
sense for the platform that's going to
be portable rather than like this
cynical like nudge towards yeah we just
want you to download everything we don't
want to manufacture games well see I I
don't think that's necessarily cynical
though I think that's going with their
with a market that that we are a lot
closer to a future of high bandwidth
areas where downloading games is not
seen as something weird or strange
having so many games now that are always
online yeah but we're based in San
Francisco think about someone in South
America think about something like
Destiny like the there are so many
really big game experiences you have to
be online to play sure yeah I just can't
see a console going entirely download
only I I think there will be experiences
and that's where the cartridge will come
in there will be experiences you can
have on a cartridge but to get a full
experience you will have to be online
for Nintendo's next console I can see
them making that if you want to get
everything if you want to be have the
full access to the library or to that's
every system right now yeah exactly and
I going to I'm just saying I think it'll
be a lot more limited in terms of what
you can get on a cartridge on what you
can get on a phys in a physical form
yeah well that's already the story with
Wii U I'm just I'm just countering the
idea that Nintendo is trying to the Wi
dire because there are no games on Wii U
well the NX the report also says it will
reportedly run on a propri proprietary
operating system designed by Nintendo
and not Android as previous reports
suggests I don't really know what propri
I don't remember those those words I
don't remember I don't know what I don't
know what reportedly means
uh what were the uh when did these
reports come out that it was going to be
Android was that a it's just all these
rumors flying around that have been you
know there's a couple sources on we're
we're perpetuating the talk confirmers
right now yes we are yeah yeah people
have a lot of different ideas and
sometimes they confirm them with sources
that are reputable or not well it was
weird because some of the most concrete
evidence of what the NX might be was
breath of the wild at E3 because it kind
of hinted at the fact that the NX isn't
going to be this complete departure from
a more traditional console experience
because it has like we were playing on
the Wii U it has to work for the Wii U
it has to work for the NX and it kind of
told you a lot but about the control
scheme it's not going to be like
something you play on your phone
obviously this game is not that that was
ever like the the main concern but I
don't know like does this kind of does
this new do these new rumors kind of
confirm what we gathered from breath of
the wild like the the sparse info that
we could kind of Garner I I think it
plays into it well that that it doesn't
defy what you might expect for a console
that will be able to play breath of the
wild because we know breath of the wild
will be a playable game on this system
but it also makes it really interesting
in in how that's going to work and what
kind of experience that's going to be I
I don't know what do you think Peter I
don't think it's gonna be very different
from the Wii U version at all well it'll
be the same game yeah that's what I'm
saying if if not better yeah so B the
question conf Bob Jones 1980 in the chat
was saying any rumors NX will require a
cellular provider it doesn't now it
doesn't sound like it right no I it's
not like that kind of mobile game I
think that would I mean Sony tried that
with the Vita and the Vita has its own
problems but that whole initiative just
proved that that's not something want
people don't want that yeah sure I'm
gonna so I've heard from multiple
confirmed
sources definitely that that in addition
to NX and in addition to Zelda being on
NX there's going to be a Mario game so
you can attribute that to me Justin with
with the scoop super Mario Universe 2016
2017 I'm getting I'm getting another
report that there will almost really
likely be a fire emblem game and an
animal crossing game for NX at some
point in the consol's life cycle
confirmed 2016 I think he's hearing 2016
no I confirm I'm confirming it now in
2016 it'll be out in sometime the next
10 years okay perfect so we don't have
to wait long maybe we do maybe we don't
um so obviously you know like Nintendo
did confirm the global release date is
March next year yeah that was a couple
months ago they confirmed that yeah okay
so I guess we're inching closer to
finding out more about that that'll be
on your birthday it might be it might be
how do you remember my birthday month
cuz I love you everyone's born in March
my entire family is born in March gross
everyone disgusting anyway so that is
the hold on there's more to say you talk
about the thing powering this thing oh
yeah Pete hit us with that kind of
hamsters I was hoping you could do it we
could do we we could do it I was hoping
you could explain it about the NX yeah I
would oh never mind do you know how
electricity works so when a proton and a
nutrino okay long story short this is as
Jimmy Tang mentioned on the lobby a
couple weeks ago uh this might be
running nvidia's Tegra processor which
is a mobile chip that is used in some
phones and tablets that's what I was
going to say that yes I knew
that and it's also their uh Android
shield uh chip and that can actually run
games uh better than an Xbox 360 and PS3
in some instances like 1080p p60 for
some games that ran 720 P30 but not all
games like something like middle Gear
Rising Revengeance ran slower on that
there's a version out right now called
the X1 it's pretty good that was the one
I was just describing we kind of know
that the X2 is coming it's going to have
a smaller manufacturing process
obviously be more powerful but we know
next to nothing else about it when it's
coming out if it'll be in this right now
it's targeted mostly to cars if it
sticks with the X1 and the rumors that
we're hearing today are true devkits
have a fan built into the thing to cool
the the chip which means you might be
playing a handheld with a fan on it your
car unless they go to this new one where
it can dissipate Heat at a much more
efficient rate and we don't need that
fan so that that's where those rumors
are coming from here's hoping that we
don't need a fan because that would be
kind of annoying yeah be like uh the
loud Xbox one that's not like a thing
that's uh my roommate Jake Decker he has
the loudest Xbox one ever and every time
he's playing it I can hear it like from
my room beneath his so if he has another
piece of Hardware that's making more
noise and driving me insane there are
lots of pieces of Hardware that make
noise in Jake Decker's
room yeah like I don't know we we talked
about this on the lobby before I get
annoyed by small noises misophonia we
don't need to get into it Pete knows
Justin knows he makes a lot of noise
that annoy me anyway so that is the
latest Bevy of rumors about Nintendo's
NX which they have confirmed will
release in March
2017 we kind of learned if this report
is accurate we it's not confirmed yet
well a little more about it detachable
controllers uh so yeah let us know what
you think are you excited for the NX do
you believe these rumors are true I
don't know tell us in the comments below
I don't know tell us in the comments
yeah so what are you guys doing this
weekend Pete yeah are you GNA be
reviewing a game or something I would
assume I don't have time for
that you just throwing reviews to
everybody else yeah I don't know what
I'm doing this weekend honestly I got no
plans man hanging out with you if you're
lucky yeah you're talking about seeing
Ghostbusters right yeah oh Tuesday at
Kabuki theater tonight it's $6 Tuesday
but it's also Taco Tuesday tacos Trump
movies get out of here yeah yeah what if
you saw a movie with tacos in it I saw a
movie about tacos they do Taco Tuesday
at the same theater shut up yeah I'm
serious so that's the thing they lure
you in with the $6 ticket but they get
you with the $30 tacos so it's really
$36 Tuesday there's not really a taco
Tuesday if it's if they do they only
serve Tacos on that Tuesday yeah I would
assume so I don't know but they're
they're high price so these are high-end
tacos if they're $30 tacos
Cuisine I don't know are you going to go
are you going to see Ghostbusters what
do you have planned well today I have to
go record Another podcast I have to go
record The Geek box you're in demand so
popular I don't know this weekend I I
need to catch up on all the trailers
from Comic Con because I didn't have
time because we were at the show to
actually watch any of these trailers so
I'm just going to like block out some
time speaking those trailers Justin
speaking of Ghostbusters yeah sorry to
just miss your Gamespot plug but uh
speaking of Ghostbusters we rode in the
in a replica of the Ecto one it was a
Lyft was doing a promotion we just did a
dumb video about it where you and I
replica of the Ecto one also known as a
hearse with a door that didn't work air
conditioning that was just middling at
Best in like 90° San Diego weather with
what 90% humidity I I wasn't happy about
it it you seemed like you were a little
more positive riding in the eect one
it's cool from the outside it's like
when you see anything really cool when
you get a new cool piece of armor in a
video game but you can't see it
everybody else can see it like oh that's
that's cool I'm I'm glad I have these
really awesome shoulders I don't get to
enjoy them sweet shoulders dude so
that's what the Ecto one was like it
looks really cool from the outside but
when you're in it it just looks like a a
car and there's a white hood and that's
really all you see but people wave at
you all right last question do you have
any games planned this weekend to play
for real this time what do you plan Abu
you're playing abzu yeah you didn't
mention that before when I asked
if you just remember it now oh [__] I
have Abu I'm uh I don't is it embargo I
might be playing live lock the uh this
upcoming which is coming out in August
it just wasn't a huge game we didn't
mention in our Roundup but it's a like
Diablo twin stick shooter if that sounds
interesting to you which it does to me I
like Diablo I like twin six shooters I
like Shooters going to be playing it a
little bit for a preview I think maybe
this weekend finally finished Doom which
is nice really really really good game I
liked it a lot I agree with everybody
whatever they're all saying so yeah I
don't know I'm going to play some more
Monster Hunter world of warft Legion
yeah Generations if you want to join me
in hunting monsters no in World of
Warcraft or Monster Hunter these are
both open I I've tried I tried Monster
Hunter 3 and just didn't grab me but uh
yeah anyway so I'll be sitting outside
your room just waiting for you to join
if you want to join in either game I'm
just saying it's open all weekend hey
Mike I mean if if you're free okay well
thanks so much for coming on the show
Justin and Pete thanks for talking NX
rumors and the rest of the games coming
out this summer and everyone who joined
on Twitch and GameSpot and anyone
listening on iTunes or Stitcher wherever
you put your ears I'm not going to tell
you what to do with those uh thanks for
joining us and you know like leave
suggestions on what to play this summer
in the comments below and thanks for
listening to yet another episode of the
lobby thanks for tolerating me uh Pete's
going to be hosting next week correct
correct cuz Danny's still in Europe
doing his thing I don't even know a part
of Europe he's in like what's the
country with the Eiffel tower Russia
Germany no yeah Germany Danny's in
Germany he's uh he's using bedet and
whatnot
uh thanks for joining us come back next
week to see Pete Brown on the
[Music]
lobby